we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i mentioned
that yes the new england patriots were
defeated yesterday in a very very good
game by the philadelphia eagles the
Eggman called in and the Eggman he's had
these sort of anti sports views for a
long time and he says we just shouldn't
care but that he believes it's good for
the country that the new england
patriots lost take a listen to what the
Eggman had to say hey Dave I think it's
kind of childish and stupid to invest
any emotion in a sporting team or
sporting event one that you're not
actually playing in any sporting team
doesn't know who you are so why do you
care about them but anyway as stupid as
it is putting your own heart and emotion
behind a national team I think it's good
that the Patriots lost because they're
just there in the national zeitgeist we
all know who they are whether we're
smart enough to know that supports are
dumb anyway and I think it just sets the
world in a more right stance
Noorie means like the Patriots losing
makes the world just a little bit better
that's all yeah I don't see it that way
but listen to each their own and with
peace and love to the eggman but that's
not that that that's just not how I see
it I know that something I guess only
like 15 percent of the country wanted
the Patriots to win and then some huge
percentage wanted the Eagles to win and
then some other percentage just didn't
care so I know people root against the
Patriots and that Boston teams in
general are often not super popular but
couldn't disagree more with the eggman
would have been great but you know what
we got five Super Bowls we've got five
and whatever maybe next year we'll make
it we've got a great bonus show for you
today I do want to talk about this dodge
Dodge Ram dodge truck commercial that
aired during the Super Bowl yesterday
that featured a speech from Martin
Luther King which I actually found to be
in poor taste I didn't think it was
racist
I wasn't triggered into some kind of
some kind of shutdown of my in cat
Faculty's mental faculties I just
thought that it was in poor taste I will
talk about it on the bonus show I also
want to talk about how the number of
people using Facebook in the United
States or North America more broadly
actually has decreased for the first
time and I want to talk about the
implications of that and I also want to
talk about how in New York all 51,000
state prisoners are going to get tablet
computers which is already angering many
many people all of those stories and
more on the bonus show david pakman.com
slash membership to sign up or
patreon.com slash david pakman show
where you can now also get access to the
bonus show I will speak to you then